We are here today with Professor Allen Kachalia, and Allen is a physician, practicing internist
at the Brigham, he's also a lawyer.
And, we are going to talk about the law, and regulation,
and how these tools are used to help assure and improve health care quality.
Allen, welcome, thank you so much for coming.
It's a pleasure to be here.
So Allen, I want to start off sort of taking a big step back,
and we're going to begin by thinking about the legal and regulatory structure in the
US.
What role does the law play in assuring that when I go
see a doctor, when somebody comes to a hospital, that the quality of that health care is at
least halfway good?
What can the law do in that respect?
I think there's actually three ways that the law helps
assure that we have high quality or care in this country.
The first is regulation, states or the federal government
sets minimum standards for which a practitioner must meet,
or a hospital must meet, if it wants to operate.
The second is the liability system malpractice, that's a system of accountability and we could
talk more about that in a second.
And then the third is when it actually creates financial incentives, or penalties, for hospitals
and physicians and other providers, with regard to how they
behave and what they do, and the ACA is a classic example of that.
So they're all really important, let's take each one of them one at a time,
if you don't mind.
Let's start with regulation, what do you mean regulation?
Give me a couple of examples of the kinds of things that we do in the US
on regulation, and what do they have to do with quality?
I think the classic example of regulation that people think of
is, you need to have a license to practice.
I think the idea there is that, if a doctor is going to practice medicine,
he or she needs to have met minimum training requirements,
so the idea is when people are out there practicing, we know they at least have a floor, or baseline
level, of knowledge that everybody will meet.
Who sets those standards of what is a minimum level of baseline?
It can vary in how they're set.
Sometimes they're set by the states themselves, or sometimes they're set by the states working
with the relevant kind of professional body, working with them to figure out what the standard
should look like.
So the state says, if you're going to be a practicing internist,
or going to be a physician, in the state of Massachusetts, in the United States,
you need to have what?
Gone to medical school, done a certain amount of post medical school training?
Correct, I believe in most states, it's either one or two years.
You actually don't have to finish a full residency to do it,
I think, in some states it's literally one year,
and then you can go and get a license to practice.
Who are other professionals in health care, beyond physicians,
who end up usually having to meet a licensing requirement?
It can include nurses, pharmacists physical therapists.
I think those are all examples of people who need to have a license,
or pass some kind of certification, before they can practice.
Got it, so almost everybody who touches a patient, in the US, in most states,
maybe all states, you need some sort of a license
before you can get involved in patient care.
We've talked about licensing as one set of regulatory mechanisms.
What else is there from a regulatory kind of thing?
What about for hospitals?
What about for others?
For hospitals, there are regulations that are set up around,
fire safety for example, is subject to regulation, or how safe the building is, it up to codes?
So it won't come down on people, so all of that is subject to regulation.
Just as is the air flow pattern in health care institutions,
because sometimes you need isolation precautions and things like that.
All of that is subject to regulation.
In some states, things like nursing staffing ratios
are also subject to regulation.
If you look at hospitals in America, if I wanted tomorrow,
to go and build a hospital, set it up, and run
it to take care of patients, what specific to health care,
would I have to do to make sure I could run a hospital in Boston tomorrow?
That's a great question, and I'm not sure I know exactly
all the people you'd have to interact with the make this happen.
I imagine you'd have to work at least with the Department of Public Health,
because they also issue regulations around what hospitals need to do.
OK, so we have Department of Public Health, what about regulators
sort of beyond?
Things like Medicare, Medicare is the biggest payer
of health care in America.
Do they get involved in figuring out like what hospitals their patients
can go to, or can a Medicare patient go to any hospital he or she wants?
One, Medicare does get involved in regulation.
For you to receive payment from the federal government for Medicare
patients, there are actually what they call conditions of participation
that you have to meet.
One of the common conditions of participation that people talk about
is, you either have to be reviewed by the government, accredited
by the government, so they can say you are up to snuff, with regard
to all the standards they've set.
Or you can undergo what's called joint commission accreditation, where
the joint commission comes in and reviews you.
I think as long as you meet all of Medicares conditions of participation,
Medicare patients can come in to pretty much any hospital that they want,
and the government will pay.
There are certain regulations that can constrain the flow of patients,
but those don't have to do with regulation on the hospital end,
they have to do with it on the patient end.
Because some patients can sign up for either what they call traditional Medicare, which
allows you to go where you want, or you can choose to sign up for something
that they call Medicare advantage, which puts you in
a capitated, or managed care plan, which can restrict your
movement.
So fundamentally, if you're thinking about who's
regulating the quality of hospital care, Medicare has an important role to play in asking you
to get either joint commission accreditation, or getting accreditation directly
from the government.
Correct, and they use the power the purse to get people to follow those standards, because
the Medicare business often tends to comprise a significant share of most
hospitals.